now we already know that biden's team is
incompetent on many fronts so in
military affairs they're embarrassing
performance in afghanistan in foreign
policy their humiliation with carrie and
blinken across the table from their
counterparts at the ccp and at the
border they're importing a trifecta of
disasters from covid to crime to poverty
but as nightmarish as all of that has
been
biden's on track to eclipse all of it
with his pathetic handling of the
economy
when you take a step back and look at
what's happening we're actually making
real progress maybe it doesn't seem fast
enough i'd like to see it faster and
we're going to make it faster
well he'll still be making this claim in
2024 it's coming faster any day now
because for the left things are always
going to improve in the future but they
actually never do
it's the ultimate bait and switch maybe
we should call it bankrupt and switch
now this could have been a slam dunk the
economy even for biden's goofballs after
all we had the strongest economy of any
g7 country in 2018 2019 and 2020. that
was all under trump obviously and
despite the challenge of covet last year
our real median household income was
more than 67 000
which was six percent higher than it was
in 2016 under obama
and thanks to president trump's
leadership biden's team not only
inherited new vaccines but an enormous
supply of them at a time when many other
countries didn't have any so all biden
had to do was number one make the
vaccines widely available number two
lift all restrictions on economic
activity and number three let the
trump-era policies and the hard work of
the american people take us back to the
booming economy we enjoyed before covet
of course they did the exact opposite
they canceled trump's policies overreach
with vaccine mandates and scared the
public into staying at home
and over the last few days we've seen
the toll that biden's radical agenda is
taking on the economy it all started
with friday's abysmal jobs report
194
whoa i see 194
000 that is real low people don't seem
to be in a hurry to get back to work
there's one and a half jobs for every
unemployed person out there america is
running out of everything christmas at
risk a supply chain disaster only gets
worse your holiday turkey may be harder
to come by this season
the turkey's going to take your turkey
well
who else wants to send biden to the
island of misfit presidents this
christmas
thank goodness santa slade by the way
doesn't need gas because the price per
gallon is up 43 percent
under biden
than it was in december 2020 wow
but don't worry
because i'm sure our energy secretary is
working hard right now to turn it all
around
we don't own
our own gas supply or oil supply
and so
the market is what the market is
presidents don't control
the cost of gasoline and we also are
aware that we want to move into a clean
energy environment and that we want
while this transition occurs he does not
want to raise costs on everyday people
for anything
well she's either stupid herself or she
thinks we are
not only do we have a strategic
petroleum reserve that was set up for
this exact type of situation
the feds control billions of barrels
worth of oil and natural gas on public
lands
so first biden banned new oil and gas
leases on public lands then
after he was rebuked by the courts he
slowed to a trickle the issuance of new
permits
now this slams working people by
worsening inflation which the angle
warned you about earlier this year as
did prominent democrats like larry
summers
but biden's so-called experts they're
always in quotes by the way when i say
experts regarding biden they just kept
downplaying it
i see important transitory influences at
work
and i don't anticipate that it will be
permanent most of the price increases
we've seen are were expected and
expected to be temporary
well last week the definition of the
word temporary changed
supply bottlenecks have developed
that have caused inflation i believe
that they're transitory but that doesn't
mean they'll go away over the next
several months
depends on what the meaning of the word
temporary means
the scenes of huge traffic jams that are
major ports where ships are idling for
weeks and even months
is another devastating indictment of the
byte administration we brought this up a
few weeks ago
new york la and now savannah georgia are
in total gridlock
our rail lines are gummed up as well one
yard in chicago reportedly had a line of
trains waiting to be unloaded
that stretched for 25 miles
but at least we have a former road
scholar as transportation secretary to
fix it for us
what we're looking at is basically
everything between
those ships and your shelves that gets
the goods to where they need to be when
we're partnering with the department of
labor to try to establish more
apprenticeships and make sure that we're
addressing that
what
did he actually say apprenticeships
were going to get us out of the
situation
heaven help us because this entire
administration is an apprenticeship
meanwhile biden's labor secretary has
absolutely no clue as to how to fix the
labor shortages
i don't have an answer for you i mean
i'd like to if i had that answer i'd be
given an all day today but i think that
one thing that i'm going to do is i mean
if i were the mayor of boston i would
have an understanding why that's not
happening so i think we dig down a
little bit more here
we went from labor secretary gene scalia
to that guy
oh my goodness when you see it all
together the totality of the
incompetence really is quite staggering
so it looks like we are in for a long
and difficult winter a winter of
shortages and disappointments especially
for americans living in cities strangled
still by restrictions mandates and you
throw the cold weather weather into that
my goodness
it's all playing out exactly as the
angle predicted instead of just
reopening the economy without
restrictions the biden team did
everything it could to terrify americans
and convince them to stay home
the folks in college stationed texas
though on saturday night they were
obviously not listening to tony fauci at
all
[Applause]
not a lot of masks there
the foolish and unnecessary vaccine
mandates did nothing to save lives but
they are pushing people out of the
workforce pilots health care workers
teachers firefighters and police
it's criminal what is being done to
these good people
the administration has resisted efforts
to return welfare payments to normal or
allow landlords to collect their rents
they've restricted the oil and gas
industry as i mentioned
now they want to waste trillions more on
new government programs that will do
more to harm our economic
competitiveness fantastic guys
common sense is out the window
in this administration we know that
and they believe that americans are
mostly racist who are destroying the
plan in any way so why should people as
awful as that have a higher standard of
living than and they certainly they
shouldn't have any higher standard of
living than let's say people living in
greece
of course if we had a real press
they'd be all over this
instead
we have pretender pundits who can't quit
their trump addiction
trump wants an army back he wants this
army to help him have vengeance on the
entire american democratic system trump
is marshaling those forces to try and
seize power in 2024 whether you the
voters elect him or not trump's reason
for being in politics is trump george
clooney called donald trump a
knucklehead in an interview with the bbc
that was just today
it went on for hours and hours and hours
well what else they gonna talk about
there's no defending biden's policies or
his performance the poor man can barely
locate the exit in any given room where
he's speaking
and sure i know you're all thinking
laura this is depressing we're in for a
rough ride yes we are for a while
but let us never give in to despair no
way i said this the day after the
election keep a stiff upper lip we know
how to turn things around and in time we
will
we survived jimmy carter we can survive
this
the carter years led to ronald reagan
and if the american people are smart and
i think they are the biden years will
lead to the new and better economic
policies after 2024 and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else